إذا سبق لك أن قلت شيئًا ما وراء
ظهر شخص ما ولكن مع جهاز iPhone iPad
أو Mac في مكان قريب ، فقد يكون هذا الخطأ
أخبارًا سيئة بالنسبة لك ولنا جميعًا منذ أكثر
من أسبوع ، اكتشف مراهق
عندما يتصل FaceTime بشخص ما
إذا أضفت آخر  اتصل عبر الدردشة الجماعية
كرنين لها وأدخل رقمك الخاص ،
ثم يمكنك البدء في سماع الشخص الموجود على
الخط الآخر حتى لو لم
يرد بعد ، ولن تعطيه شاشته
أي إشارة مهما كانت
المحادثة تنتقل حتى
أسوأ من الخطأ  عرض أيضًا فيديو
مباشرًا للشخص الآخر إذا ضغطوا على
زر مستوى الصوت على جانب
جهاز iPhone الخاص بهم معتقدين أنهم يرفضون
المكالمة التي تقول Apple إنها حددت
إصلاحًا للمشكلة
وستصدرها وتحديث البرنامج في وقت لاحق من هذا الأسبوع في
هذه الأثناء  تقول الشركة إنها بدأت في
تعطيل ميزة FaceTime الجماعية
لجميع المستخدمين ولكن لحماية نفسك
في غضون ذلك ، يمكنك تعطيل FaceTime على
جميع أجهزتك على iPhone أو iPad ، انتقل
إلى s  إعدادات FaceTime وتبديل هذا
الزر الأخضر في الجزء العلوي من الشاشة ، عثر
طفل يبلغ من العمر 14 عامًا في ولاية أريزونا
على الخطأ أثناء يوم عطلة
من المدرسة ، أمضت والدته أسبوعًا في
إرسال بريد إلكتروني إلى Apple وهي تغرد الرئيس التنفيذي لشركة Tim
Cook وحتى ترسل رسالة بالفاكس إليها
خطاب رسمي لشركات المحاماة عند إصدار تحديث iOS التالي ،
ستحتاج إلى الترقية على
الفور وفي الوقت نفسه قد يكون الوقت مناسبًا
لعدم قول أي شيء سلبي عن
أصدقائك أو عائلتك على الأقل ليس مع
أي من أجهزة Apple المجاورة Samuel Burke
CNN London